good evening ladies and gentlemen thank
you for coming to this evening's
planning West Committee in front of me
are the other counselors who are sitting
on this committee to make decisions and
he decided me our officers of the
council who will assist us to introduce
themselves legal services charlotte dick
Senior Planner Louise Corman Senior
Planner Cole Reed environmental health
lovely so we'll go to the agenda and
apologies of absence
chairman apologies receive from counts
for Atkinson token councillor fielding
is substituting councillor organ from
councillor Kendall is substituting and
councillor Vaudrey for whom councillor
Crump is substituting lovely thank you
and thank you for substituting and
turning up tonight and before we do
begin I'd just like to wish Peter Barnes
a very happy birthday okay are there any
disclosures of interest I'll start
I've had many letters over 20 on the
first garden application I know a lot of
other members have that as well so I
don't think we all have to declare that
anything else can
in relation to their first garden
application as part of my role as an
adjacent ward member I attended a
meeting between the applicant and other
ward members in relation to that I took
a full note of that meeting and the
content of it if anyone would wish to
inspect it I'm satisfied that I come to
this application with an entirely open
mind and I've also seen the
correspondents in objection to this
application as well
so councillor Joyce was that land off
Langley Road that's first garden 1806
for one thank you German I attended a
site sending in the Langley Rhodes one
I'm member but I haven't made any
representation I am here thank you very
much okay so if we owe the minutes of
the last meeting
are we all happy with the minutes of the
last meeting so confirm first planning
application tonight item number four
Langley Road
Clevedon Thank You chairman and the
application is a part retrospective full
application for change in site levels to
paddocks in connection with an adjoining
housing development the position of the
site is denoted by the black dot the
site is located off Langley Road to the
west of clavata the application site is
edged in red to the north of the site is
a recent development of four dwellings
which has not yet been completed the
application site have permission to be
used as paddocks associated with dots
two and three
this plan shows the housing layout as
approved in 2016 no ground levels was
included on the plans approved in 2016
and the levels shown are the original
ground levels submitted in 2014 the
level contours show rising ground levels
across the site from east to west this
plan shows the final levels proposed
along with the proposed drainage as can
be seen from the contours the land would
be leveled to the rear with plots
two and three with steeper slopes
towards the east and west of the site a
land rain is proposed across the site
fed by channels to the site and a
further drain is proposed at the toe of
the sleep to the western boundary of the
site as recommended by the applicants
ground investigation specialist this
slide shows a section through the site
from south to north showing the final
proposed levels
this one shows a section through the
site from west to east showing the final
proposed levels the section is to the
front of the neighboring property this
one again shows a section from west to
east to the rear of the neighboring
property
this shows a photograph of the western
boundary of the site taken from the rear
of the paddock land and this one shows
the existing contractor's compound with
reading her to the neighboring property
in the background the excavation still
to be carried out is to level the ground
under the compound area and this slide
shows the abundant of topsoil and the
property in the background and the
compound this topsoil would be spread
over the site and planted with grass and
chairman there are updates on the update
sheet and the recommendation is to grant
the applications subject to the
conditions set out on page 15 okay thank
you now
we normally did this before but there is
a quite a considerable amount of comment
on the update sheet and some information
on the update sheet so I think we'll
have a few minutes to go through that
before we go to the speakers if needed
okay thank you so we'll move to the
speakers sorry about that
first of all we'll hear from the parish
council covered employers council
councilor Simon Lawton as chair who has
three minutes good evening
thank you and thirsty council aspartyl
those who were able to make it on behalf
of the parish council can i thank you
for your time to visit the site I think
you will find it was useful and explains
in a large girl why Clara and parish
council have objected his application in
the officers report it states that the
leveling works were required do and I
quote poor quality uneven land not
suitable for request during use a
committee this land I can assure you has
been used by horses for many years
certainly over thirty plus since I've
been in the village
it was my pleasant gently rolling past
year as you can see from this pic of how
it was to prove the point use a picture
of the last occupant of this field on
this basis The Parent Council refute the
argument that the land was unsuitable
for horses now on page 81 the report
advisors that works such as this must be
fully justified I quote again we as a
parent Council don't not for you that
this is this condition is satisfied and
disagree with the report in the does not
satisfy policy AS 10 which is very clear
on this point on page 82 the report
again suggests that in the opinion of
the officer the works do not have a
significant visual impact the parish
council again disagree and have a
different view the views from the public
footpath near to the site and our local
sledging field are effective the
character of the landscape has been
significantly altered in what was a
gentle sloping hill is now a bowling
during flat acre of land the parish
council which the land should be
returned to its previous state despite
any short-term inconvenience we fail as
a parish council the inconvenience in
previous state is not a reason to let
this remain as is again the report
dismisses any harmful Greenbelt effect
the parish council will again argue that
over two meets
of depth of soil removed must have a
harmful effect on the Greenbelt and
contrary therefore the policy cs10 now
this is probably more importantly as
compounded by the protection the site is
afforded under policy CS 12 the site and
the area forms part of the Arden special
landscape area policy CS 12 says the
high landscape quality of the special
landscape areas will be protected by
resisting development proposals would
have a harmful effect of this effective
character and appearance which make an
important contribution to the image and
enjoyment of the district surely this
vandalism goes completely against
policies yes 12 and on that reason
gentlemen and ladies I think that we
would like you to refuse this
application on the three grounds I said
there are technical issues which the
neighbors will come up with thank you
just first of all you were mentioning
page 81 and 82 we've got its page
something to fill maybe so yes there's
been see if I can go back over some of
those reasons then the last one was
Arden special landscape CS 12 before
that was landscape character I believe
yes 10 CS 10 and then your page 81 what
was that well this was the justification
chairman I'm given that the works would
take place in the first place the
justification was that the land as such
a gently rolling former pony paddock was
not suitable for equestrian use okay
that is the justification we completely
refute that and I would suggest he goes
against a s-10 thank you cash the bombs
question or clarification you wear them
all the buildings were that they were
using to build they're proposing to take
that down as well
and the other thing was in the red line
when you first started there was no
mention of any conditions on this band
no I mean in your first point as I
understand it yes once the porta cabins
or whatever that that the site will be
leveled some of the spoil
will be spread over the site but I
believe a majority of it will be carted
off site it is intended to be what is
now a level field looks like a bowling
green of about an acre where it used to
be a gently rolling paddock your second
point if I think what you asked me I
think that in the original planning
application this land was a part of the
planning application and we can ask that
technical questions thank you any other
questions no thank you very much and we
will now hear from objectors mr. and
mrs. de from the neighboring property
and mr. AI Harbin who is the advisor for
mr. e mrs. J so I presume we've got a
mr. de here mr. Harbin okay and is there
any kind of speed you both speaking or
yes the depo planning to do the initial
three minutes and then any questions
okay so is that okay go ahead you have
three minutes we have some pictures here
if we can just bring those up very
briefly as I go through for a couple of
seconds on each one if we can flick
through them this is just gives an
alternative view so this looks from our
property across you can see to give some
scale you've got a van and the container
next next slide actually shows you the
depth of the excavation it's much more
indicated here you can see there's two
point one meters at that point we click
on to the next one you can see this and
I love you back that's the amount of
soil with the then you build at the back
so that under the container is going to
be moved we move on to the next slide
please and you can see our property and
a line to show that it's
five point one meters to the fence and
you can see that the proximity of the
slope I think there's another photograph
after this one as well which is looking
back to give you an idea of the extent
one more please okay that's looking the
other direction which gives in the other
side of that mound of topsoil you can
see it's quite a considerable amount of
excavation I think the final one just
there gives you a sort of an overall
plan view of the amount of saw that's
left so if I can carry on then I'm at
fainting committee for visiting to
assess the works from both points of
view our primary concern is that the
work will destabilize our land and
property over time the planning officer
in a sum up stated that the application
does not meet the requirements of the
core strategy to quote policy cs9 states
that proposals should ensure a good
standard of amenity for occupants of new
and neighboring dwellings and that they
will be protected from unacceptable
levels of noise contamination pollution
loss of privacy in daylight and adverse
surroundings in our opinion this
retrospective application contravenes
policy cs9 because if granted the works
will have a direct and ongoing adverse
effect on us those neighbors excavating
the amount of previously undisturbed
clay along side a property could lead to
movement or slippage the latest
sectional drawing is shown for one
location and does not show the effect
along the boundary the developers
engineers report supporting application
confirms an increased level of risk to
our property it is unacceptable that we
as immediate neighbors should be exposed
to this increased risk we strongly urge
the committee not to grant this
application because removal of the
remaining land will be irresponsible and
it is a gamble that could lead to our
future financial loss due to loss of
property value through uninsurable 'ti
and saleability or damage through actual
failure note insurability is not been
tested with our an under item our
consulting engineer Ian recommends that
no more earth should be removed if
reinstatement of the paddock is not
enforced in all of the remaining land
beneath the containers in canteen should
remain undisturbed
this could mitigate some of the risk to
our property there's a generic comment
in the report submitted on the 26th of
November and also 20th of January
regarding the water attention profile of
the clay in the slope of the cutting
however there is no indication that any
assessment has been made of the effect
on our adjacent land and the foundations
of our property due to changes in the
water table trying shrinkage cracking
and
and slippage and movement of the clay
subsoil caused by the work undertaken
finally the rep respect retrospective
application was for leveling of the
topsoil and drainage purposes members
saw that the works more accurately
resemble major engineering earthworks as
undertake of highways the applicant
refers to the land stability section of
the national planning practice
guidelines this is for instability
caused by mining presumably due to the
amounts of snow removed the applicant
wishes the excavation to be treated as
open cast mining thank you spot on thank
you are there any question okay Thank
You councillor Richards we've we in our
update sheet we have information and
forgive me for looking down I'm just
reading you I want to make sure I get it
right because I find it very confusing
the factor of safety against a failure
of a slow 42 meter high cut an angle of
14 degrees is one point seven when fully
saturated and higher if dry can you give
us some idea of whether you a agree with
that and be what it actually means in
plain English okay well I haven't gone
into in-depth analysis of the SLO
suitability of that land I don't feel
it's my place to do that I think what
it's fair to say is that both myself and
mr. Lister agree that there's an
increased level of slope in stability as
a result of the excavations and that's
that's really where our position is
there is an increase in risk and that is
agreed and admitted by the applicants
engineer but at this stage we don't know
what tool you can't confirm to what
extent that increased risk is we know
there is we haven't agreed that no okay
thank you very much so now we will turn
to the applicants and agents so that's
Liz Nicholson and Phil Sangha
so I've recognized this Nicholson okay
yes I thought you would recognize me Liz
Nicholson planning consultant Phil
Sanger you met at the committee back in
December who spoke and this is Howard
list who is director of ground
investigation specialist limited and
he's been providing engineering and
geotechnical advice for the site so I'm
going to do the speaking and then the
other guys here for the questions as you
wish and you have six minutes thank you
so as you know the application was
deferred in December for two reasons to
allow members to visit the site to
consider any impact on landscape and a
request was made for further technical
information in laypersons terms most
councillors were able to attend the site
visit and you would have seen for
yourselves that there is no harm to
landscape it is worth noting that before
excavation work commenced on this site
this was not a beautiful paddock a
sizable part of the field had been used
as a dumping ground in association with
commercial activities on the front of
the site and Jackson developments have
had to one to take a large task of
clearing the site without regrading
laying of topsoil and receding the land
would not be fit for any purpose given
its previous use after the December
meeting mr. Sanger and mr. Jackson
approached mr. and mrs. day and
requested a meeting with them to better
understand their concerns and seek where
possible to ameliorate these as mr.
Sanger explained to you at the committee
meeting in December he will be living
with his family at the property at plot
3 when it is completed and he wishes to
be a good neighbor with regard to the
concerns related to noise and vibration
the offer has been made to use smaller
machines for the remaining excavation
work and this could be confirmed
directly with the days should planning
permission be granted allowing work to
be resumed to finish the site with
regard to the concerns relating to
engineering and land stability we
provided a sectional drawing prepared by
mr. Lister then in response to further
comments for me and Harvin acting on
behalf of the days we submitted another
response to your office's yesterday if
you have any questions about Landis
ability and then obviously mr. Lister is
here to answer those it's always been
clear that this is an application may
partly on a retrospective
basis to seek approval for engineering
works on the land at the back of the
four houses that are currently being
built the majority of the excavation
work has been carried out there is one
part remaining which you saw on your
site visit cross-sectional drawings have
been provided along with details of the
proposed drainage as well as the
landscape drawings confirm the spread of
topsoil reseeding of the paddock whilst
these are matters that could reasonably
have been left to conditions they have
been provided as part of the application
submission to provide clarity on the
nature of the works for the benefit of
the neighbors and parish council and
yourselves the excavation work stopped
in March last year when Jackson
developments were revised by the council
that planning permission was required
ten months on the delays in planning
permission being granted and now having
a severe impact on the completion of the
houses as the ground source heat pipe
work and the drainage works for the
houses have been delayed pending the
outcome of this application if
permission is granted it's the intention
that all of the material from the final
part of the excavation works will be
reused within the site land drainage
works will be carried out in accordance
with the submitted drawings so that the
topsoil can then be distributed and the
land receded as a useable paddock and
flower meadow this paddock and meadow
will not form any part of the garden
area for the houses so in summary on
where we've got to now you've seen from
your site visits any impact on landscape
we have provided you with detailed
responses from our geotechnical expert
on the matter of land stability and he's
here tonight to answer any further
questions you have heard from your
officers that we have met as far as it
is applicable to this application the
requirements of national planning policy
guidance in respect of land stability it
remains our opinion that land stability
in this case is not a relevant planning
matter this is a civil matter between
the two parties the flowchart in the
National planning policy guidance
supports our view on this my clients
have engaged in a dialogue with their
neighbors to try to ameliorate their
concerns and will continue to do so
outside of the planning process your
officers recommend the approval of the
application and there are no
evidence-based reasons for refusal
having addressed the reasons why the
application was deferred at the Planning
Committee on the fifth
December which is now eight weeks ago we
ask that you grant the application thank
you very much I have one question you
mentioned the flow chart I've read about
it could you just remind me what it's
called and what it's for yeah the flow
chart from the National guidance is
really about where the land the existing
for development where the land is may be
unstable so in the very first instance I
would question when this is the only way
in which the national guidance talks
about land stability where the land is
unstable so you know a mining area or
something like that
so there is a question to me that
actually we fall outside the planning
process completely because the only
guidance is about existing instability
even if we go down the flow chart it
says once you've provided your
information there is no requirement to
carry out independent assessment of that
we've provided information and therefore
we should get to a decision okay thank
you very much
are there any other questions I think
there was before I was involved before
the work stopped in March yes I think
some of the material was taken off we're
not saying at all that the land is
unstable it's stayed as it is since
March nothing has happened and that land
has not moved
okay Kesha Giles I think it said on
behalf of object is that one possibility
is that no further land should be
removed so that which has been excavated
would be as it is or as proposed to be
but the part with the caverns on would
stay as it is and be put into the
landscape so that there
any further issues what does the African
have a view on that
yeah I think and hopefully you'll agree
from the site visit that you couldn't
just leave it as it is to leave it as it
is is going to look really quite strange
as I've said to finish off that land
that material will be distributed across
the site that's the intention
okay Costa Perry Thank You chair I'm
particularly interested the parish
council made reference to the historical
nature of the site having been used for
equestrian facilities that what were the
reasons for changing it and digging it
down below if it had been perfectly
acceptable for equestrian facilities in
the in the past I don't actually think
that's a planning issue because if these
works are acceptable in planning terms
the reason why the applicant wants to do
it and what the Parish Council says
about the condition of the land before
is not actually councillor Giles about
the argument put by the parish councils
it it's contrary to a s-10 because there
ought to be a specific justification for
it and and there is and there doesn't
appear to be one and their argument
what's your response to that I think in
terms of policy like I say you have to
look at whether there is harm I think
that's a planning test for any
application is whether there is an
acceptable harm and in this instance I
would say there isn't it okay any other
questions nope
thank you very much okay so we're not
hearing from so we can go to technical
questions if any if so army counselor
Richard thank you
the Atlas engineering stuff just beyond
me it doesn't make sense it kind of
makes sense but if we had our own stuff
done our own engineering it's not part
of any specific planning policy in the
core strategy that we would ask for such
engineering okay my concern about that
is very clearly if it does the land does
collapse it does have a significant
impact on neighboring property and
therefore by definition having that
significant impact would be a breach of
a s-10 so surely it makes sense for us
to have done that rather than relying on
the word of an applicant over the word
of someone who could well be significant
help me with that one a little bit if
you would
counselor you said if it has if it
collapses there would be an a s10
consequence this is significant impact
on neighboring community on neighbors
and the collapse of a wall is definitely
significant impact
Sherman whip we're speculating that
there may be some movement in this
ground they have submitted expert
evidence to that effect they've complied
with the National Planning Policy going
from officers perspective that we have
pursued the planning system in the way
despite the fact there's contrary
opinion from an expert from the
objecting site you're entirely
comfortable and happy that what we're
presented with here pretty clearly sets
out that there will be no impact to that
land it won't collapse Casa bombs going
back to when I started in the respective
this application went through with the
land as it was there were no conditions
on it they decided to reduce it and
therefore they need planning permission
is that is that correct what I'm saying
is I think we've got that yeah why is it
here
what so there was no condition put on
the redline it was in the redline
conditions
cancer Charles
on page 12 of your report you refer to a
s10 stating that all of the forms of
development will need to be fully
justified offer significant benefits and
and not the contrary to the overall
development strategy and then obviously
miss Nicholson presented will detest it
actually but really unless it causes
harm it's going to be acceptable I'm
just wondering what our test is and what
what exactly we're supposed to be
looking at so I can be clear I mean I
think in this case and the main test was
the impact on the landscape and that's
looking at the works when they're
finished and seeded with grass whether
that is significantly different to be to
the landscape character in the area
Canterbury
thank you chair I would just welcome
some clarification around policy C s 12
special landscape areas where the Parish
Council made reference to the fact the
site is within the Arden special
landscape area and that obviously that
area has a distinctive character rolling
hills etc and obviously this is dug down
and then flattened I just welcome your
views on the impact of this the the
application in front of us being judged
against the special landscape area of CS
12 on page 13 looked at the impact on
the landscape I've looked at the
landscaping in the vicinity of the site
and the fact that the levels changed
quite dramatically on either side the
fields aren't necessarily flat but I
concluded that it's quite screened by
the existing and hedges and trees around
the site and that actually once it's
grassed over that I don't think
character canceling can I just be clear
if there has clearly been a change to
the landscape it's a special landscape
area there has been a change to the
landscape the testing front of members
is whether that change to the special
landscape area has caused harm and if so
what harm and you must be very
crystallized some of that cancer field
as far as I know there were no stable
shown on the original planning
application it was just shown as
patterned and there's no stables on this
okay we move to debate okay mister that
care about well I went on the site visit
although I wasn't going to but
fortunately my wife went to borrow a car
is nutsen yes so I attended the summit
visit went back and she's all clear
I was looking from the down the road the
way I came from the church I could see
it for some considerable distance I'm
not happy with what has been done at all
I can understand the neighbors concern
and I do know a bit about soil because
he just moved
it's just cracked it's alive it just
moved and as far as I'm concerned I
would like he put back as he bought most
of the land ran there was uneven pasture
land if you want to put it that way is
the way I'll put it not like a bowl in
green
and as far as I can see looking from
where I did originally and I think the
ward member was walking the same way you
could see for some conditional distance
I would like it put back as it was they
expect your policy I do feel that even
in which all that saw was taking away or
push down towards the brook and then
it's all green down it won't look in
keeping with the surroundings as they
are thank you very much special trials
completely agree with counselor bonds I
don't think I've ever said today to be
you know if this application had come on
before it had actually been done I think
it would have been really difficult to
justify and I can't help look at a s ten
which does say the development within
the countryside has to be fully
justified and offer significant benefits
and look to minimize the impact on the
character of the local landscape and
minimize impact and I think have I been
judging it when the work wasn't not have
said I just can't see what the
justification and benefit is and I'm
concerned about what it's going to look
like in the harm now I'm looking at it I
definitely think that because I agree
with counts lavon's I think it's visible
I think it's not you know leveling the
landscape or creating it in a fashion
which is different from the sort of and
undulating and actually special is
exactly the word I would use for the
landscape around there it's very special
in in a literal sense under technical
sense so I'm inclined to agree with
counselor Barnes and I would certainly
not want any further earth removed and
I'd like it to go back to how it was
yes you can kind of fielding
want to improve the view from the houses
also the topsoil if what we were told
was full of rubbish and everything else
surely that topsoil it's not okay we'll
have a few more talks then we have a we
have a second information Chancellor
Perry Thank You chair I too attended the
site visit my concerns relate to both a
s 10 and also CS 12 which I think
dovetail very neatly in together because
we've got the specialist landscape and I
think it's the cumulative impact of a
number of these policies I think if you
look at the policies in isolation
you know the harm isn't significant but
when you actually we've got actually
four for call street call strategy
policies we've got CS 9 on its design a
distinctiveness we've got a s 10
we've got CS 12 and I and I think it's
it's the cumulative impact of all these
policies I think if you just look at
them in isolation which I appreciate the
the planning officers have to do but
adding them all together and I think you
know the whole special landscape the
Arden the whole character around this
particular part of Clarendon and Langley
is very significant and and I would be
going against the officers
recommendation interesting okay
lovely obviously you realize what you
came up with a lot of policy numbers
there which is good so I'm sure we can
we can find a reason the proposal in the
second would have to mine those policies
for to define their reasons but
for wanting to refuses personally I'd
just like to add that I won't be voting
against this recommendation because I
came to look at it as well to look at
the site as well with those feelings in
mind that you know this is a very
special landscape
this is countryside I don't like the
idea of people cutting into it and
changing it and and that's what we're
here to stop however when I got there
and okay now it's all bare clay so it's
very striking but within I I just felt
that with in that particular location
within within the within it situation
when it was grassed over it would have a
very minimal impact and and I do
strongly consider the impact it would
have
and and I felt it would be a minimal one
and therefore although I am strongly
against the idea of what's being done
here and I agree with counselor jealous
that I might have struggled beforehand
having having seen it now it's done I
think the actual level of harm is is
quite low and therefore I will be
agreeing with officers on this one
councillor Richards so first one
refugees or come back on what you just
said actually when you you haven't seen
the landscape as it was what you're
doing is comparing the landscape now
with it now so you can't quite clearly
make a decision on the impact that it
has had to meets a change in ground
level is quite significant to my mind I
know you've obviously noticed from my my
questioning my my initial line of
thinking was whether or not there is
likely to be an impact due to land
slippage I can't make a decision based
on the information I've got and I was
mind at that point to abstain Chile on
the basis I can't make a decision based
on information that is not really clear
to me however having listened to
and particularly councillor Perry who
was rounded off with the cumulative
impact of all the issues that have been
raised by our members I'm more minded to
support that line of thinking
particularly because we're talking about
an odd a special odd in landscape area
it's special for a reason and sticking
bulldozers through it and taking two
meters off soil and clay off remove some
of that special nature so if we are if
with our proposed I'm not entirely clear
of the reasoning for the proposal but if
we are going to go along that route I
would like to hear it
articulated properly but particularly
include that cumulative impact in it
okay so we've got we've got a we're
going to go to the vote we've had
councillor Perry's cumulative argument
of CS 12 CS 10 is 10 c s9 largely about
landscape I think it's all about
landscape is the reasons and officers
have heard our discussions and I think
those policies reflect our discussions I
think that's a Bailey
it's our officers happy with that as a
prospective reason I'm hearing that
members consider that the application
conflicts with several policies what I'm
not quite hearing yet is why well I
think you've heard the fact that you
know a 2 meter gouge in this particular
location makes a big difference you've
significant thank you you've heard that
this particular location is very special
because of because of the and flats all
the fields Randy's left as they were
three million years ago they haven't
been told that's the reason that it's a
special landscape area a big flat piece
right there we are I think
that's I think that's absolutely you
know I like that I don't think we need
to add to that is that okay good so with
that as a reason
with or without we fleshed out that
passionate reasoning from councillor
bombs very good we shall go to the vote
with the yellow cards we are voting to
go against officer recommendation and
with and refused application 1801 for
when I fall
the Clevedon all those in favor of
refusing the application for the losers
given do I feel silly all those in favor
of granting so we have resolved to
refuse application 1801 for 104 for the
reasons given thank you
so we shall move swiftly on to
application 1703 o89 seek roof space
are we ready yep thank you ladies and
gentlemen the next application
Thank You chair this application is 17
for stroke zero three zero eight nine
ful for sick roof space in Ulster Heath
and Ulster
the application has been brought before
members last year on the 23rd of May the
West APC members deferred the
application pending the receipt of a
revised noise report and an additional
external lighting assessment these
reports have been now provided by the
applicant and the application is now
being determined on this basis the
application site identified in the black
dots on the map is located in Ulster and
lies the west of the Birmingham Road and
the east of Ulster he throwed the
application site is outlined in red and
the plan and shows the site in context
with the surrounding development broad
Lane letter business and residential
dwelling known as high trees like
immediately east of the site residential
development to the north open land to
the west and the residential dwelling
known as Heath fail and the turnpike
house office building to the south the
site lies within the West Midlands
Greenbelt and a number of public
footpaths identified by the patch
screening lines are located on the plan
lie within the vicinity the site
operates as a general industrial use
specializing in the manufacture of roof
trusses and Timbers raw materials and
finished products are stacked around the
periphery of the site and the factory
building itself has used the
manufacturing process of the timber
trusses this application seeks to erect
a single-story extension onto part of
the northern elevation of the building
identified by the pink area here
this is the extension zoomed in the
building is proposed to a measure 4.6
meters in height with a floor area of
229 point nine square meters the the
extension was proposed to serve as an
acoustic Lobby to assist in reducing
breakout noise emanating from the
factory when the existing automated
roller chatter door opens encloses which
is on the existing elevation so this is
the existing northern elevation this is
the existing roller shutter doors this
is the main one and a fire door
emergency fire door and proposed to
enclose all of that area with the new
structure here with new roller shutter
door on the Eastern elevation of the
extension where they fire door as well
the intention is to have an
interconnected so interlocked system so
with the existing roller shutter doors
and pedestrian fire door on the north
and elevation to ensure that effectively
when one door opens the other remain
shut and vice versa and that old the
daughter should at all times when not in
use the application also seeks to revise
the operating hours with of the business
which currently are restricted to Monday
to Friday 7 o'clock till 6 p.m. and they
are seeking to increase this from 7
o'clock to 9 o'clock Monday to Friday
within the service yard which is the
area outlined in orange and 7 till 9
o'clock
within the factory itself so it's 7:00
till eleven o'clock within the factory
itself in addition they are seeking to
operate between a 7 o'clock and 1
o'clock on Saturdays
storage areas are restricted currently
to a maximum height of six point two
meters around the periphery of the site
so this is within these areas here just
to remind yourselves the there is a
loading area within the site for the
hdvs which is in the central part and
hdvs
are supposed to wait within this area
here so to hahdve vehicles aren't able
to wait within this zone as part of the
development and they are proposing to
introduce a new traffic management plan
which effectively will enable the doors
which serve the service yard and
currently are closed during operating
hours and only open upon the arrival of
a HTV which does sometimes cause
congestion on the main Birmingham Road
here so they are to remain open during
operating hours so an up until 9 o'clock
those will be remaining open and
introduction of this new waiting area
together with the loading area the
proposals also seek to revise the
landscaping scheme there are some plans
a lime trees located within the entrance
of the site you'll see there wasn't a
photograph in the shortly but it's
proposed to realign the existing fencing
and setting it slightly further back
into the site remove the existing lime
trees here and replace them with some
hornbeam trees at a height of 4 to 5
metres together with some understory
planting and also a real we plant the
removed lime trees and plant them on the
other 7 area of the entrance together
with gapping up of along the existing
eastern landscape boundary so planting
some along here as well so this is
in diagrammatic form these are the
existing lines and these are the repose
or replacement horn beams so you can see
in terms of relationship to the racking
which is to the north of of this access
so the show the relationship so over
time effectively the idea is that it's
going to improve vistas in and improve
screening the green circles on the plans
indicates existing lighting and as part
of the revised a lighting strategy these
lights are proposed to be replaced there
are existing mobile towers within the
center of the site these are proposed to
be replaced entirely and no longer used
an estate have some fixed columns so
thereby the directionality as an impact
of the lighting will then be fixed
together with the other fixed lighting
points around the site turning now to
some photographs of the site itself so
this is the area where the extension
would be located two of these existing
floodlights would be removed this
existing racking would be also removed
and the extension would effectively
encompass all of these doors here this
is the northern boundary with existing
vegetation and trees this is a view of
the eastern boundary so the bamboo sort
of the Birmingham Road as it's beyond
this is a view of the existing entrance
so you can see the existing trees along
this Vista so these are going to be
replanted along here
this is again a vista showing the where
the racking is again along the
Birmingham Road and this is again
looking northwards showing a viewpoint
of the road there I do take the point
that it probably is going to be raised
by third parties that it is in the
summer months so it is in full leaf if
there's less the screening in the winter
periods this is a view looking
southwards along the Ulster Heath road
and finally this is a view of the
entrance there's this is a staff car
parking area and you can see the racking
sari stacking that's it sorry
they there are a couple of updates to
note these include the removal sorry
these include the removal of the Town
Council's objection subject to a series
of criteria which I'm sure they're going
to be expanding upon an amendment to
conditions 7english a include the
requirement for automated timer on the
external lights in the service yard the
inclusion of an additional condition a
number 20 regarding height marker on the
racking again this is in response to the
comments of the Town Council condition
number one is also being revised
together with the introduction of
condition 21 which also restricts the
opening of the new emergency access
pedestrian door and eastern elevation so
chairman and the recommendation is to
grant Planning Commission subject to the
revised wording of the conditions one is
7 and the inclusion of conditions 21 and
20 20 and 21 and the remaining
conditions and notes as outlined in the
committee of course thank you thank you
so we referred to the update sheet there
and it continues on the next page in
comments if you want to read those on
the
second second sheet third party letters
of objection if anyone wants
okay so if we move on to the town
council
professor Clive Neil Sturges from Ulster
Town Council good evening and as you
probably know you have three minutes and
I'll tell you when you've had two and a
half Thank You chairman yes I'm Clive
nails they're just chairman of the
Ulster Town Council planning committee
thank you for the opportunity to speak
the Town Council planning committee
considered this application at its
meeting on the 21st of January when
seven residents attended and gave their
views considerable views although I am
registered to speak as an object the ATC
Planning Committee following advice from
the offices of SDC wishes to submit a
response of no objection to the revised
application as we have no evidence base
material considerations to contest the
views of the operators but we wish to
make representation on the enforcement
of the following conditions prior to the
start of the proposed increase working
hours one that noise a lock is in place
and an external physical indicator light
of the raccoon has already been included
by the officers all lighting to be
automatically time and controlled has
already been accepted by the officers we
would ask that the traffic management
plan be implemented immediately as it is
still the case that occasionally HGB
trailers are sticking out over the a45
we did ask for monitoring noise levels
at the boundary to comply with the
environmental protection officers
recommendations however we've been
advised that is not normal practice due
to resource constraints so we would
and asked for a site visit on completion
of work to ensure compliance also as
this third time we consider the
development members of the committee
wish to express the disquiet
over-planning creep well though we
appreciate that company's development
circumstances change what we've ended up
with is very different from the original
application thank you
thank you very much I you mentioned the
noise lock needing to be done after nine
o'clock well at all times that's in
that's in the condition I believe the
noise lock yes I think what we what
we're saying essentially is that the
change of working hours etc should until
after the noise lock has been built okay
thank you
questions Costa Perry thank you chair
good evening cancer just wonder whether
you can confirm in approximate terms as
far as yards are concerned how far the
nearest residential dwelling is from
this site I'm afraid I can't it's
probably on the officers had slides
considerable field between this site and
the residence which is owned by the
resident and which purchased by the
residents to form a buffer but it's
really to do with the noise generation
when that big Rolla door is open and the
manufacturing noise but I was across to
the resident okay thank you
sorry no that's on a different aspect of
the site they found the residential
houses that are complaining are north of
the works where is that it's across the
Oh 435 it's the other side around okay
great any other questions
oh thank you very much okay so go to
another objector Mike
drink water yeah so you've got three
minutes press the button so the red
lights come on thank you well I won't
distress that the neighbors have a real
concern that the will beat enjoys
disturbance in the evenings if this
application is granted the applicant
submitted a new noise report after last
last meeting when the committee
requested that one be produced the
residents have demonstrated that the
report is wrong and even the eh-oh
provided comments supporting the fact
that there are errors in the report I
would ask that the committee stick to
their request and seek a full and
accurate noise report before considering
approval there remains no traffic
management plan against which to grab
this application this is a fundamental
requirement for many reasons including
safety the original permission for this
site was granted following without
following procedure
there was no notification to neighbors
as required
the original planning consent report
stated that it it is both necessary and
reasonable to require materials to only
be stored in specific defined areas and
for materials to be stored no higher
than 4 meters clear policy reasoning was
given for this the fact this fact was
totally ignored when granting later
planning permission
perhaps pressure was exerted because it
was a retrospective planning application
but no justification for change of
policy was provided now the current
committee report is issues and uses
historical failings to justify further
development on the site I hope the
committee will consider whether
continuing creep of this development is
appropriate for its location the current
report emphasizes the elements of policy
that would permit this application it
does not present the elements of policy
that protects the amenity and which must
also be used to reach a balanced
decision losing valuable seconds I have
examples of these policy breaches or
policy I would also like to just stress
on the last meeting a number of things
were said that were inaccurate it was
said that the site would look better now
than it did before
it's absolutely absolutely ridiculous to
suggest that 30 seconds it was suggested
that the cold storage wagons must have
been as high as the storage this again
was false information at the last
meeting the Eddy stopped our lorries 4.2
3 metres high
not 6.2 it was stated that Kings codon
was already pretty industrial looking
and so it was acceptable to permit this
development the bias shown in this
statement is
I'm afraid that time I will be cut off
there I stumbled a few times that's
alright I promise you for some of your
examples you mentioned but didn't have
time to give policy I think you were
thinking of some policy numbers perhaps
sorry I do have some policy numbers
unfortunately when I left the house I
left all my documents behind will have
two CS ten is ten the Greek the
Greenbelt policy in particular I might
actually have three examples although I
don't have the remainder the policy
state I haven't got the number that the
states that it relates not only to
physical appearance but also to such
matters as landscaping control of noise
etc that's in one of them and so we're
not looking just at the design we're
looking at the impact of that design
comes in that policy another one states
that individual settlements have their
own distinctive character and that these
are highly valued and need to be
preserved for future generations this is
a fundamental principle the council's
and the last one I have is that the
policy on green belt states that the
strategic objective is that the rural
character of the district will have been
maintained and enhanced and I see no
enhancement okay thank you okay so the
bans any other questions no thank you
very much thank you and we'll move to
Richard Irving from ID planning and
Kevin Sherlock who is presumably the
applicant Kevin Sherlock okay please do
and you have six votes so tell me what
you're going to do with them
probably won't a counselor but chair
members of committee my name is Richard
Irving and I've been acting on behalf of
SiGe roof space since the company first
took occupation of the Abbie Mills
industrial unit in 2015 and I'm joined
by Kevin Sherlock who is the managing
director of SRT roof space and following
this short presentation we are more than
happy to answer any questions you may
have clearly share the description of
the development is evident on the front
page of the committee report and is
exactly the same as when the application
was presented to you last year consents
approved for the new side extension to
the northern elevation of the principal
building and a variation of the
operational hours on the consent
approved in 2017 chair just to reiterate
from last year's presentation the
specific reason for this application is
it's simply the overwhelming success of
the company since it took occupations
from three and a half years ago house
building has continued to grow and this
has had a significant impact on the
business and their ability to
manufacture and deliver the finished
product to meet orders and on time the
company has grown significantly and now
employs in the region of 250 staff and
will look to employ further staff and
Abby Mills should planning be approved
chair you'll recall this planning
application was presented to committee
last year with a recommendation for
approval but you asked us to review our
noise data in conjunction with the
council and the environmental health
officer and further recordings were
undertaken and your Environmental Health
Officer still concludes that the
extension will offer acoustic protection
to nearby residential properties you
were all we were also asked to look at
the external lighting and again we've
provided further updated lighting plans
which again the council's environmental
health officers supported that end chair
these were the only two reasons why the
application was deferred last year since
that deferral we have worked extremely
closely with your professional officers
to produce even more robust evidence to
support the application chair by
approving this application which is
subject to a number of conditions that
the company accepts as being appropriate
and reasonable this will allow the
company to continue the positive
economic output output and continued job
creating opportunities this increase in
productivity
can only have a benefit on the local
economy chair members we have genuinely
worked diligently with your officers at
your request to present the most
comprehensive and robust evidence to
support the application which we are
pleased is continuing to be supported by
the professional officers and will allow
the company to maintain a strong and
national presence over the coming years
chair members we have asked and and
delivered what you have asked us to do
after last year's committee meeting and
we'd simply urge you to recommend
approval of the application thank you
Thank You councillor Barnes you thank
you I was one that proposed deferment
you were concerned about two particular
lights on the northern side two lights
that were at a wrong angle so they were
confirmed and they've been put down and
then one of the reasons about the mobile
light at the far end which is obviously
gonna be removed based on will be a
fixed light of the fixed point
okay so fielding correct on that
increase stuff yes so the proposed at
the moment we have one shift that works
in the operating hours when we go to two
shifts there'll be an hour's distance or
difference between the first shift
finishing and the second shift starting
so the moment takes approximately 15 to
20 minutes to basically for every to
leave the building so that we've got an
hours grace between getting one shift
out and the second shift in okay
counselor Club
yeah so the moment the first shift for
the factories are answered over 100
employees so the power be to get up to
another hundred employees to basically
to replicate the first shift in terms of
employment everything is done locally so
we pull from ideal if we get everybody
from Auster I'll be perfect for me so
where we pull from Ulster Redditch Eve
Shem all the local areas we use for temp
agencies hence while we do get a lot
more people now come on their bicycles
okay
one for me I'm concerned about that the
change to Saturday working
I consider that a weekend in general and
7:00 o'clock start outside seems very
early to me on a weekend so do you have
any comments or I mean if you could
suggest 9 o'clock there's a start
outside on on a Saturday would something
like that be possible
for for you to consider obviously seven
o'clock inside but no rolling around and
banging and crashing and the work yard
until 9:00 yeah I think what we've done
is well we've provided the noise reports
the actual obviously environment offers
about a firmness that there's actually
no difference in noise on Saturday
morning that it is on Monday to Friday
so again I don't know I'm not an expert
but in further Saturday's I think if you
probably look to industry normal working
day okay thank you
there is a problem there the actual
fibers are actually moon sex it's so
they are allowed you know it's next to
the building so they are allowed to you
know go out in so it's not actually a
fire door so I think we can ask that in
technical one more the other one is that
is there going to be enough space for
for the lorries depart three lorries
that can be yes so at the moment the
plan shows now that there's two Arctic's
that can actually sit into the loading
area and is actually even with the doors
open you can still get to Arctic's off
the highways a comment earlier was about
that they're hanging over at the a 435
from the gates back to the end of the
bell mouth you know an artic you know
it's a full art it length can get off
that highway so even without product but
even the loading area if you look at the
actual plank orange areas there's enough
space to probably put another 20
Arctic's if we ever have to so Khosla
bands sorry to come back is the recycle
rack yeah there's actually a space for
writing the nor that one on the north
will be the south west elevation top of
the green parts there's actually a bays
there we've some picnic benches where
they par the bikes I'm just going to go
back to councillor Fielding's question
about the fire door it's just the fire
door which is on the east of the new bit
it's the door it's the door that'll
being closed by the lobby inside the new
building correct okay so what's this
door I can see I'm looking at here next
to the roller - that is an exit door
pedestrian exit door and is that
conditioned in any way to open a closed
you know you know the conditions on the
roller shutter doors so that can open
while the internal door is open it is a
pedestrian door - yeah that can be
opened and closed yes okay well we get
to that untechnical I think we will be
forever yes kinda fielding my concern
it looks like there's a far door halfway
along the building which could be open
and therefore admit noise I don't know
whether whether the drawing just shows
that or it's just my imagination we will
do that on technical yeah okay any more
questions thank you very much okay so
technical questions we'll go to this
fire door one first oh I'm so sorry
councillor Adams every time and you're
wearing a red sweater as well sorry
the main objection I got is I don't
think the site is suitable for the
increased working hours it's very close
to residential properties increase can
you come closer don't normally ask it
but I think the officer is done the
first-class job in the recommendation
she is putting the report and the update
sheet and if you're mindful to grant
this application can I ask you to
support these conditions thank you
Thank You counselor any questions no
thank you
technical questions and I'm going to go
to accounts of fielding first on vitals
bring on the elevation it looks like the
there are far doors along that side of
the building
are they alarmed to stop them being left
open or am I wrong in my assumption of
the understanding of the plan as far as
I'm aware they're not alarmed from yeah
okay sorry these ones so right so these
are on the that will be on the western
elevation thanks the ones you're talking
about
these ones in the middle there's one in
the middle desert and then you've got
the one over because you've got the
offices at the far end and then you've
got some steps leading into some doors
underneath the logo okay if we can have
Environmental Health Officer comment on
that monkey chair
what I would recommend is the condition
stating the all external doors and
docking stations in the manufacturing
area should be closed at all times
whilst manufacturing is taking place
that is to protect the minutes of the
area and to prevent noise where they
ship and indeed that is what we
Environmental Health would like to see
and I'm sure that is the intent I think
that covers everything but is there a
way we can ensure that on a piece of
paper you could look to to seek to
actually interlock all those doors if
you wish to however
CCTV is a condition which I've
recommended ctv CCTV can be utilized to
enforce that condition and is a less
expense to the applicant what it will
achieve the same goal very good thank
you very much cash to Barnes yes in
environmental terms the reason that we
were concerned last time they have never
been addressed
am i right through the chair the
applicant has submitted a more robust
acoustic report and dare I say an
impressive lighting report which the
isolux data was very good in my opinion
if that is implemented in accordance
with the drawings has indeed the
acoustic report I see that there will be
an improvement in the environment
you care so Richards a couple of things
first of all the condition set out by
the town council I haven't gone through
all the conditions tried to very quickly
tick them off
are you satisfied if we were to add
these are you satisfied that they can be
part of and also if we were to add the
condition that all the fire exits or
other exits are in fact fitted with auto
closed mechanisms from an environmental
health point of view yes I would and
equally if I could just pick up one
matter which was raised earlier
validation of all the works there was a
suggestion a measure and confirm I would
suggest that the applicant undertakes
the validation report ok that's useful
I'm going to pick up on those points and
I am going to go through them on the
Ulster Town Council comment you've got
the external physical indicator included
you've got all lighting to be timer
controlled yeah you've got landscaping
now traffic management plan that was
mentioned several times do we have a
traffic management plan or is it just
the gate drawing here which identifies
that the gates okay so it's where they
can park and the fact is going to be
received by the applicants setting out
the criteria there and that that can all
be checked by CCTV yes
and it has to be recorded for a 28-day
period so if there are issues that are
arising then we can request to see that
okay and we're happy with the validation
report to be the final thing and all
these are going in at the right time so
these things have to happen first before
the new timing operations can go on the
timings of the some of the elements the
landscaping has to go in landscaping
will be when when it can be yes but I'm
thinking of the noise reduction and the
light reduction the operating hours so
they can only be implemented if the
extension is constructed so the
extension to the hours can only occur if
the extension of once the extension has
been completed so one can't go without
the other in terms of the the lighting
that also has to be implemented prior to
the implementation of the extended hours
so so they're all interlinked and what
is the only way at what have suggested
that you know can we fund tomorrow start
this open gate policy or not so the
because the hours is tied to the however
there is nothing to prevent them from
opening their gates from tomorrow
matters okay thank you any questions
kind of a fielding concerns me is
lorries and notorious for no arriving on
time
and therefore to prevent lorries parking
out on the street out on the road is
there some means of either security that
will allow them to be taken straight in
or do they just have to wait until seven
o'clock in the morning through chat and
as far as I'm aware that the lorry
drivers do call ahead that's normally
what occurs I think my la enabling the
gates to remain open during working
hours we don't want them to be stacked
up before seven o'clock the the
management of of this site should be
that allows the vehicles and naturally
to flow through the site preventing the
the stacking on it on the the question
knows if something arrives at 10 past
9:00 and the gates are shut and
nothing's allowed to go in because the
lights are off and there's no work on
the hood what have a stone lorry is can
we manage that well we have we have on
previous applications but can't okay we
will have one more to perhaps expand my
previous answer
we could certainly incorporate hours of
arrival and departure for lorries
we might not I don't think we need to
actually so we'll go to debate anyone to
debate can't let Charles an application
like this you know both parties that we
hear from have entirely legitimate views
we have a wonderful business owner who
is looking to expand an employ locally
and we have residents who were quite
legitimately concerned about how that in
packs on their immunity and ability to
enjoy where they live I I really do
actually think that all parties here
have obviously worked really really hard
to come up with something detailed
enforceable I do compliment the
applicant for their hard work and
cooperation I think obviously the
planning department have worked really
hard and I personally incredibly
satisfied that this is is just a really
thoughtful sensitive way of looking to
expand a business whilst taking into
account the concerns so I'm extremely
happy to propose it a grant for this
Carol Richards thank you so I was sat on
the original committee that deferred and
the reasons for that what I'm really
pleased about is that has obviously gone
away worked with our environmental
health team answered the questions that
we had I'm now very satisfied that this
would fit with I'm very very pleased
that in the 18 months they've all moved
forward they've all worked together and
I'm sorry where they defer it before in
the respect of lorries I've got five
hours he's being built right opposite to
school and the Builder knows exactly
where the lorries are all over the
country and what time they come in and
they can talk to them buy a computer for
some reason forever so it's quite easy
for a company to do it fully support
building I support the application
providing we can just in the management
make notes with regards to the fire
doors and also as we've discussed
lorries and movements okay so we had
various suggestions one was a validation
report are you happy to include that yes
I think it's a good idea I mean I think
the proposal was a site visit but that
seems to me a more comprehensive way of
doing it and then the other one was
automatic locking doors do you want to
include that Auto close close stay open
yep
happy ok nothing else so so okay we've
had a proposal a second all those in
favor of granting thank you so we have
resolved to grant application 70 no 309
are you taking a break
okay we'll take five minutes and I mean
five minutes were started 22 the one
with bold
okay welcome back we are now going to
our final application first garden
Stratford which was deferred I'm sure
we're hear all about that from Charlotte
Thank You chairman the site is indicated
on the map by the black circle the
application site is located located on
the western side of the town centre and
within the Web Filter power boundary and
conservation area of stratford-upon-avon
this slide shows the application site as
a red circle located towards the bottom
of the slide the site was only
pedestrian access due to its position
within affairs garden a public park the
red buildings and railings indicate
listed buildings whilst the pink line
which is visible on the left-hand side
of the photo denotes the edge of the
conservation area the three green
circles indicate trees which benefit
from a tree preservation order this is
an application for full planning
permission for a Chinese peony pavilion
motion was deferred from the 9th of
January committee in order for
additional soft landscaping details to
be submitted this slide shows the
amended proposed block poem showing the
location of the pavilion in relation to
the nearest trees on the site as well as
their respective reprojection areas the
plan on the right-hand side of the
screen is a zoomed in version of the
same plan this slide shows that proposed
North elevation of the pavilion on the
left-hand side this elevation would be
replicated when viewed from the southern
side the pavilion is a church
traditional Chinese design and would
measure 6.5 meters in total height the
floor plan on the right-hand side of the
screen shows that the pavilion would
measure SiC would say which features six
sides and would have a footprint of
approximately 11 square meters this
photo is taken from the south east of
the application site with robert's tree
in the foreground looking north three
firs garden the junction with chestnut
walk is visible on the right-hand side
of the photo and part of grave road can
be seen on the left-hand side
the approximate siting of the pavilion
is shown by the yellow array the
screening which would be provided by the
soft landscaping in suggestive condition
three would limit fees for myself
this photo is taken from the south west
of the application site facing north
along Grove Road the southern part of
burrs garden is visible centrally within
the photo and the approximate location
of the pavilion is shown by the yellow
arrow again this photo is taken from
within firs garden close to where the
police station is located the photo is
taken facing south towards the
application site which is indicated
again by the yellow arrow in the
background of the photo this photo is
taken from Radha streets facing across
to Grove Road the approximate location
of the pavilion is shown by the yellow
arrow again the two visible pedestrian
entrances to fairs garden are those
noted with him suggestive condition for
which are proposed to be dr. this slide
shows a photo montage of how the
proposed pavilion may appear when viewed
from Grove Road no scales or dimensions
are included so this photo is included
for guidance purposes only this image
shows the proposed landscaping plan
showing that a huge and shrubs are to be
located to the south and north of the
pavilion in order to comply with the
county highway screening request just to
clarify there are updates within the
update sheets officer recommendation is
to grant poor planning commission
subjects the conditions found on pages
54 and 55 of the agenda and the amended
conditions within the update sheet thank
you
so just some updates have been it the
applicant has asked her to show us some
information which is mentioned in the
update sheet but this committee very
seldom accepts such things so I think
it's unfair to do that this time when we
don't normally do it I've had and I'm
sure you've all had many letters from
local residents in the main
and I should go over those now they
talked about the peace and tranquility
of the gardens the openness and special
nature of the gardens that there are
better alternative locations that will
be antisocial behavior caused by this
that there is an Edith Carol memorial
that would have to be moved for this to
go ahead there are road safety safety
issues from a pedestrian and car point
of view there were tree damage issues
and there are pedestrian access to the
park issues and there are issues about
pre-consultation
and the number of consultation letters
that went out to residents and I have
never listed letters to me before but
the number of letters I received this
time was was greater than anything I've
ever seen so I felt I should I should
put that out there to the committee not
all of those reasons I will highlight
our planning reasons but they whether
they were the reasons in the letter do
you want to say one thing before we
because we're gonna go to speakers okay
I'm sorry degree I think we all got
those letters so we've all seen them and
understand them and have read them and
what I didn't realize at the start of
the meeting when we were going through
is actually the speaker is known to me
in a professional capacity though
speaking on behalf of the residents we
have not spoken about this thank you
very much for that and on one final
matter before we do go to the speakers
it's come to my attention
there was a printing issue over new
information being given in bold
initially councillors were given a
report which didn't have the bold type
in you've subsequently been given a
version with the bold type in
the words in both are the same they just
weren't in bold okay so we were now
finally go to our speakers you can help
me with that so we don't have anyone
from the Town Council
we do have objectors we have two
objectives mr. David Curtis speaking on
behalf of residents with mr. Thomas no
one objector with mr. Thomas Baxter mr.
Simon Savage to answer questions if
you'll step up that's great
who's David Curtis okay
Thomas Baxter okay and I recognize the
name Simon Savage from one of the
letters but mr. Savage okay so mr.
Curtis you have three minutes when
you're ready I'll tell you in you've got
30 seconds left thank you I'm speaking
on behalf of local residents concerned
accounts of his ignoring local feeling
and its own consultation guidelines
which require it to seek opinion before
decisions are reached and increase
involvement of local people in important
decisions that impact on them last
week's Herald letter has over 200
signatories there are over 60 objections
on the planning portal and councillors
have received numerous emails and
letters objecting while very few opposed
the gift the proposed site will have a
detrimental impact on the neighborhood
cannot meet the council's aims nor
satisfied donors wishes that it be a
prominent and accessible site residents
have raised the following issues
antisocial behavior the council has a
statutory duty to design out crime
closing entrances and screening to roof
height creates us haven for drug and
alcohol abuse rough sleeping graffiti
and worse residents good work in having
the alcohol restrictions own imposed
will be undone by counselors who will
create an environment where local people
especially the L
villian young will feel less safe and be
discouraged from using the park
despite this the council has not
consulted police or the police crime
Commissioner nor intends doing so which
is inexplicable road safety this 20 foot
high red Pavilion will increase traffic
dangers at one of the most
accident-prone junctions there is
nowhere to park it's surrounded by
double yellow lines or over stretched
residential parking there are no
pedestrian crossings and the roads which
border it are very busy there is no
tourist coach parking so coaches may
stop on-site creating a further safety
hazard environment the site is bounded
by beautiful mature trees which will be
damaged the pavilion is taller than a
double-decker bus is incongruous and
will dominate the space Council
development planned identify the first
as a valued open space and says
development that would harm its value to
the local community will not be
permitted unless there are very special
circumstances 300 local residents are
not convinced there are special
circumstances there are more suitable
sites which meet the need to promote
tourism Crowne Plaza for example with
the appearing River and theater backdrop
gives better access and better photo
opportunities for our Chinese guests and
tourists certainly better than traffic
queued down even place time is pressing
but that is no reason to take a bad
decision in haste we respectfully ask
councilors to refuse permission and
instead seek an alternative temporary
site in time for the Shakespeare
celebrations while suitable permanent
site is identified and proper
consultation that seeks opinions and
increases involvement of local people is
carried out thank you for your time Jen
[Applause]
thank you very much are there any
questions
care scrum I'm paraphrasing put me wrong
I put me know if I have it was accident
black spot or were you employed and have
you got have you got evidence whatever
sorry
I've started our finish well it isn't
that there are frequent accidents there
I've lived just up the road I live less
than 100 yards from site I've lived
there for 18 years and there are
frequent accidents the last one I saw
was in fact just before Christmas
they're often not reported to either the
police or ambulance services because of
the nature they tend to be very low low
speed impact but there are very frequent
accidents there yes certainly okay thank
you just remind people in the audience
today that we're only hearing from
registered speakers and it's going to be
annoying for you not to be able to jump
in and across but we can't have that or
it just descent ok we have to go the way
we go which is listening to the
registered speakers if you disagree with
something violently I'm afraid you're
going to have to keep it to yourself
because that's the way we run it and it
won't do any good going against that so
I appreciate how difficult that is there
any other questions No thank you very
much thank you very much indeed
and now if you want to sit back down
again I'm sorry we didn't ask you in the
questions
we have the applicant this Liz Nicholson
great and Toni perks and counselor
kettle and mr. Dean ding the Chinese
representative of Suzhou to answer
questions councillor kettle is the chair
of the council welcome and mr. Dean
welcome Tony perks is a senior officer
of the council welcome and his Nicholson
we've met before lovely having
consultant you have three minutes thank
you
I'm going to rattle through what I want
to say as quickly as possible and
hopefully leave a little bit time for
mr. ding just a couple of words at the
end the last committee meeting council
was raised several concerns we've sought
to address all of these the principle of
the proposals is supported by policies
in the core strategy and in the
neighbourhood development plan as you
know an application should be assessed
on its merits if the principle of
development is acceptable and if there
is no unacceptable harm caused by the
proposal then you should not consider
alternative sites you should only
consider alternative sites if you
conclude that the principle does not
accord with the development plan or if
there is some form of harm caused we
have provided your officers with the
list of considered sites and the reasons
why these sites are not suitable based
upon these reasons we hope you'll agree
the first garden is the best location
for the pavilion having received
comments from a local resident the
update sheet last time advised you that
harm could be caused to tree roots our
tree consultant has suggested an
alternative construction method and your
officers have raised no new concerns in
this regard County highways officers
originally had no objection to this
pavilion they then changed their minds
and objected then they changed their
minds again and said there was no
objection if conditions were attached
too close to pedestrian access points
and provide a landscaping screen two
point three meters in height the last
committee it was clear that you are not
happy to impose those conditions without
further information we have therefore
provided a report from a high risk
consultant
assess the accident data in this area
over the last five years and has
provided reasons why these conditions
are not necessary
we hope this reassures the committee
that permission could be granted without
imposing either of those conditions at
the same time we've also asked Simon
White who has worked as a landscape
consultant on many projects with the
council over the last few years to
provide a landscaping scheme that meets
the highways requirements if you wish
for it in our opinion a 2 point 3 meter
high hedge is unnecessary for highway
safety and this is harmful to the street
scene it removes natural surveillance
both into and out of the garden and it
takes away longer views through the
garden which provides an attractive
green space in an otherwise urban area
if the members agree that the hedge is
not required for highway safety reasons
we ask that the landscaping condition is
amended and we could submit a revised
landscaping scheme of low level planting
within one month of the decision and
provide this landscaping on site with
the first planting season after
construction we hope now that you feel
able to grant permission and I'll leave
mr. ding to say the words even in
chairman and the members community
members and councillors and the area 20
in this room for the evening my name is
ding-ding I'm here honored to present
the city of futo senior members of the
city of Whittlesea the government's busy
the last year at the add to the propose
of the site and I can assure the
committee that we they were very
comfortable with the zai the location
and that this classic a Chinese gift
represents the peace and the tranquility
and we believe this can enhance the sea
Rena tea and the harmony of the first
garden
thank you thank you very much everybody
that's three minutes we have questions
councillor Richards I'm really pleased
that your dignitaries have come and
they're they're happy with the site I
wonder what their view is
having two point three meter hedging
around the pavilion are they happy with
that what they'd rather see low-level
planting sorry this little be difficult
to me to answer now I understand that
you're saying the defense outside the
garden that we've discussed of the
Chinese delegation and when they came
over sort of in summer last year we did
take the delegation to the site and
showed them at the time we suggested
that we would put a planting scheme
around the pavilion but we didn't share
any details of them and certainly at
that time I hadn't anticipated it being
two point three meters high okay thank
you and it claims the bonds effect on
the trees the implication when you've
just spoke yes
we've looked at the foundation and
design again and we can sort of find the
building on a grain beam that only
requires about 230 mil penetration of
the ground and will support that on the
series of screw piles which the
agricultural consultant is confirmed
should have no effect on the tree roots
it'll be on a ring of concrete supported
on a series of piles and then a floor
slab will be cast above ground level
we provided details of that to the
officers and their consideration and I
understand kinds of fielding I'll start
this moment to sort of pick that up I
understand that as a local authority we
have the right sort of put pavilions up
this permitted development under the
regime the GD P o as part of our sort of
public infrastructure duty the issue
with this building is it's more than
four meters in height
so having a pavilion in that location is
something we could do without planning
concerns but because it's a traditional
Chinese pagoda with us through
with the feature roof that falls outside
of the permitted development
restrictions and entry bringing into
committee today okay thank you
councillor Perry can you advise the
neighboring trees nearby the allocated
site how often will they chose the
location quite carefully which the
initial tree survey that was revised the
picked up to avoid the canopies of the
trees so the only works we would
anticipate sort of Doom's of the trees
and normal maintenance we do have to
look at the Crown's of those trees in
that area from time to time sort of let
light in but I wouldn't anticipate any
works other than that would be required
Castle Richards thank you you've made a
point about highways and that they've
not objected objected not subjected
subject conditions and then you inferred
that potentially those conditions
weren't necessarily required anymore
can you elaborate on that and
particularly where the highways do
required more don't the final position
of County highways is no objection if
there's two conditions one to close the
pedestrian accesses and the second one
to provide a screen the first off they
said they wanted to full height so that
would be six and a half meters but later
they revised that to three two point
three meters so that's the County
highways position we've asked they how
is consultant independently to look at
that they've looked at that response
they've looked at the accident data for
the last five years and in light of the
nature of the accidents where they
happened what type they were they say
you don't need those conditions though
those works closing the access points
and the landscaping screen will have no
impact in terms of the types of
accidents that have been recorded over
the last five years so we've we've tried
to give you the two alternatives of
here's the landscaping scheme if you
wish to do so to accord with what
highways they're asking for if you don't
wish to do that
the highways consulted
hopefully reassures you that there are
reasons in their opinion that you don't
need those conditions great councillor
fielding people are gonna rough sleep
and drink and drugs in there surely if
there is a hedge around the front of it
it's going to make it even more
invisible if it's open house any thought
being about that sort of problem I don't
know whether highways have thought about
that but that's exactly why we wanted to
give you the alternatives we think the
landscaping scheme at 2.3 meters would
be create more harm than good and we've
also got a high risk consultant who's
saying you don't need to provide that it
will have no impact upon the nature and
type and frequency of the accidents that
happen there is an intention as Tony
said to provide a landscaping scheme but
we would suggest it could be low-level
plants to complement the pavilion so in
essence we're in agreement with you okay
thank you any more questions
no thank you very much everybody so now
we go to the ward member this time I
remembered council eventually I've
written it down in big writing for me
you have five minutes thank you very
much I like many of the residents who've
raised objections to this project a very
unhappy to be here again raising the
same planning reasons for refusing the
positioning of the peony pavilion on the
apex of the first garden no objection
whatsoever is raised about the Pavilion
itself and indeed residents are anxious
that a solution is found for his
sensitive application according to the
applicants presentation at the previous
hearing the pavilion will add to the
economic vibrancy of the town this is
not a reason to place the pavilion in
the first garden but to place the the
pavilion in the town for me there are
two irrefutable planning reasons to
refuse this application first and
foremost is safety the first in fact is
a peninsular traffic island sitting in a
junction complex ranked as seventh most
dangerous on Mauritius worst cluster
sites with 15 injuries in a five-year
period too serious apart from the weekly
shunts and near misses that we've heard
about known pedestrian crossing anywhere
to get to the pavilion visitors walking
to Anne Hathaway's cottage come to the
cross in it rather sweet chestnuts walk
to access the pasture shortly seeing the
pavilion it is obvious many visitors
unused this complex Junction who make
the crossing to the apex of the first to
visit the pavilion the Lea will attract
more visitors its intention is to
attract more visitors increasing
itinerant road crossing here groups who
will come especially to visit will
present further danger in crossing this
to me is the key reason to refuse this
application in fact busy roads was used
by the district as one of the reasons to
reject the site in front of the Crowne
Plaza Hotel fearing highways would
object
there are timed crossings there space to
accommodate the visitors visitors safely
and tan jiangsu spirit will be in
dialogue with Shakespeare in sight of
the theatre
a celebration of silent angler
creativity it's important to note at the
further are no stopping points for coach
or car for a quick photo op that we all
are used to on busy sightseeing holidays
there was no nearby coach Parker
suggested at the last planning meeting
second reasons for refusal central the
nature of the furs itself this peninsula
traffic island is unsuitable for the
pavilion as it does not give the respect
I believe the gifts of the gift warrants
it is a small space on the edge of the
town and the mainly residential area
which is much appreciated by locals as a
quiet green space in this busy part of
the town I believe it has protection
under policy CLW one protecting and
enhancing existing community facilities
and CLW three protecting and enhancing
existing green spaces of the NDP
residents see this as a community space
against gift from Murray qur'anic and do
not want to see it developed as a
tourist site as it does not have the
required safety infrastructure this
space should be protected in order to
ensure that a suitable quantum and
quality of recreation and amenity space
is available for the neighborhood area
the firs is listed under this policy for
protection sadly this area subject
trying to social behavior from time to
time and on occasions the police are
called the placing of the pavilion here
may increase his difficulty the pillar
of the pavilion may well become a
nighttime attraction for the wrong
reasons both mitigation suggested by
highways would not make this pavilion
more acceptable here closing the gap in
the wall would result in people climbing
over the wall and residents do not want
their traditional access to the garden
taken away from them if the proposed
planting mitigation was to be agreed
then this will contrary the NDP policy
be for designing our crime I ask you to
reject this application on planning
grants given and respectfully ask the
district to call an urgent meeting with
Ward and adjoining room sorry Ward
members to progress either a temporary
siting of the pavilion and there is
evidence that this Authority was used
temporary planning applications as was
done at snitterfield airfield and that
was give time for this council to meet
its deadline for the Shakespeare's
birthday celebrations and take longer to
find a proper solution to this
difficulty sorry I got a cold my voice
was giving out I hope you heard what I
said thank you very much
questions no out castle bombs I don't
know whether I can ask this there is if
we were to approve this this landscaping
seems to be of concern do you want it io
low or do not want to answer I don't my
Night's Dream I'm not sure how relevant
any planting in here is to the safety
issues of putting the pavilion here the
safety issues really ought to do with
groups of people crossing a road at the
seventh most dangerous site okay a
difficult question well answered no more
questions thank you very much counselor
okay
technical questions councillor Jones the
speaker said it's taller than a
double-decker bus I just wondered if
that was accurate or what you know what
we could Anna analogize the size would
you just be a can you just make it
really clear to me what the dimensions
are just so I know it was outlined but I
just want to be really clear and about
that and I don't suppose you could have
it with reference to one of the
photographs so the total height of their
pavilion would be six point five meters
the ground level would be just not 0.5
meters above the existing ground level
on the site which is why it's actually
6.5 meters to the top of the bridge
so sorry it's approximately 3.3 meters
ground areas about 11 square meters okay
can Tyler Perry Thank You chair
could I ask the officers for classes a
clarification around temporary planning
permission a if the application in front
of us could be temporary planning
application or what would the timescales
be for selecting another site for
temporary planning a planning permission
on the basis that we all think this is
the most wonderful gift and we
understand the time scales involved that
would be really helpful thank you
practice guidance buildings that you
don't give temporary Commission's
temporary Commission's are reserved for
excuse me for uses of land counsel
practically mentioned the field gliding
Club which was the use of land where a
building is proposed it's not normal to
give a temporary permission my advice to
you would be to ask a specific question
of the applicant whether they'd be
willing to accept a temporary permission
but I'd be fairly surprised if they did
counselor Richards thank you Jeff I've
two questions actually one that's been
prompted by cancer Perry so if we were
on those lines my understanding is that
this is being dug into the ground by
half a meter and has to be set so
suggests to me it's impossible is that
correct
yes thank you
it's one of highways issue I raised this
last time and I'll read it again we've
obviously had a report a professional
report from the third party now
suggesting that closing off the
two pathways and the need for a two
point three meter hedge is unnecessary
is that the position obviously is still
the county I always want those
conditions but given we've got that
evidence can we are we in a position as
a count as a committee to remove those
conditions it's within the gift of
members to use their judgment to weigh
the evidence before them and come to a
conclusion the highway report that's
been submitted by the applicant has
looked at this matter in more detail
than the highway Authority and to accept
the conclusions of fiber report it's for
you thank you further we have ignored
the highways authority before for good
reason and if we want to do again here
and there were to be an issue as a
result of what impact is that likely to
have on it what come back to highways
have on us as a as a council if
something were to go wrong but as I
understand it highways would have no
come back could possibly have a come
back as a consequence of the decision
you're taking tonight incredible to be
it's possible to demonstrate that just
going further on that as well if you
don't mind the onus of evidence would be
on the claimant is that correct or would
it could they just say yeah that's it
and we have to prove that actually it
wasn't
it's if you went against highways in
this case it wouldn't be based on no
evidence you've got a professional
report submitted to you that puts an
alternative conclusion your insightful
to place weight on that you're going
against highways based on no evidence at
all it would be an evidence-based
approach yes sir
Barnes just this clarification on the
landscaping is it is up to us to decide
whether we want a 2-meter landscaping or
no landscaping is that correct yes the
landscaping scheme that has been
submitted by the applicant is in order
to satisfy the highways objection which
was previously in place and the
suggested condition it would be a
members gift though to to look into that
further and either place of a further
condition to look for additional
information to be provided if if you
wished
it's a nice thought chairman know with
permitted development you either comply
in which case it permitted development
or you don't comply in which case the
entire development requires permission
and obviously you must evaluate it and
all its impacts so I can't encourage you
to give any weight to that structure
could be built at four meters high
it's not this structure and this is a
structure you must consider members okay
can we go to debate Council Charles when
this very first came before committee I
was I was I was quite bored lying about
it actually and initially I think as I
expressed last time I kind of thought
actually maybe this is an opportunity to
rejuvenate a certain area but I have to
say since I've since I've really looked
at all the evidence in detail and I have
to say I do find Council of fragile E's
representations quite compelling and I'm
conscious that she has a very detailed
understanding of this area it's adjacent
to my ward I find a lot of them quite
persuasive I think for me one of the
issues is I don't think I'd quite
appreciated how big the structure is and
I am concerned that it doesn't quite
have the sense of place here that it
deserves I think we talked last time I
think we talked last time about the fact
that actually the nature of the
structure and the culture attached to it
it and I think perhaps in the parry had
said last time it deserves a sense of
space and I reflected on that and
actually I think there's a lot of weight
on in that for me I personally feel I
think one of the comments is it would be
intrusive and dominant in size compared
to the particular area it's being sited
in and I think I have to agree with that
I think on this edge of Junction I think
I think it would be a shame and I think
we can do better than that I think it
deserves and I think it's I think in
terms of Road Safety again last time I
have to say it I actually took
completely ruled that out as being an
issue that concerned me I just thought
it I'm just not seeing it you know
traffic isn't distracted but the
pedestrian issue does concern me I walk
that Junction all the time and it's
really difficult and people it's it's
almost like a sort of a jaywalking
situation and actually whilst there's a
pedestrian crossing to get from a part
of the road that isn't a good pedestrian
crossing to get into this site and it's
incredibly busy is incredibly difficult
and I think that the point about
accessibility is a really good one we're
looking for this to be something which
is accessible and able to be used really
well and I just don't think it's
sufficiently accessible at all and I
think that for me it's probably one of
the biggest issues with it and I think
it hand-in-hand with that being a shame
in terms of the enjoyment of this
wonderful wonderful wonderful gift I
think it's I think there potentially are
pedestrian safety issues I have to say
I'm slightly less convinced around the
car safety issues and whether people are
distracted at looking at it but given
its size I suppose it's a possibility
the transport information concerns me
ice it's highly unusual that we would
ignore high County highways and actually
the advice often from planning offices
is really that's highly inadvisable I'm
quite concerned that we've got a
supposed to transport report that's been
separately commissioned that
tahiry's don't appear to have had the
opportunity to comment on so we're
essentially being given conflicting
evidence at the moment we're told County
highways have said that they feel that
the accesses should be blocked up and
there should be some screening that
indicates they've said it for a reason
and we haven't actually had from them an
explanation as to well actually okay
it's not necessary and I have to say
I've expressed major concern last time
screening would be highly inappropriate
blocking of accesses would be highly
inappropriate and I agree I think there
are issues around the antisocial
behavior I think it's quite difficult to
keep this park safe clean and free of
anti-social behavior so I have to say
this this application has been quite
difficult because initially I really did
start out you know very quite on the
fence about it and I feel the more
detail I've heard the more concerns and
planning concerns I think the final
thing to say is it would appear to me
that there are alternative sites and
locations and that appears to be what's
pointed out by the applicant and I think
there are better ones from what I've
heard and I think the Crowne Plaza is a
good potential location I think exactly
what counts the fragile e said about it
having that interrelation which ship
with Shakespeare and it being prominent
really important but I think the second
thing is I mean I am actually really
saddened to see that we're potentially
looking to make a decision that doesn't
enjoy community to support this is an
application which is supposed to be
something that is welcomed with open
arms how awful that we should even
consider citing something somewhere that
a huge portion of the local community
just are not happy with and and the
local councillor we've got to have
consensus on something that's such a
wonderful gift I just don't think we can
do this it doesn't work by imposing it
on people that's not what I don't think
that's what any gift giver would want
and so I just think that would be wrong
so for those reasons I would actually
and I'm sorry I've been very long
because there were so many pros and cons
and but sorry but for that reason I
would
thank you very much very sad councillor
Richards Thank You Shannon there are a
couple of things that I do agree with
from councillor Giles but I don't agree
with her final summation first of all
and there's a number of things that were
number of processes that I'm going
through in order to make a decision on
this first of all the the siting and the
location whilst not necessarily in
everyone's mind is the best we're not
here as a planning committee to make a
decision on where is the best location
we have to look at planning reasons in
this location as to why it shouldn't be
there my my view so looking at the
pedestrian side of things first of all
there are two pedestrian crossings
through signals traffic lights on on on
the I'm sorry please to not make any
comments traffic controls pedestrian
crossings on the junction
I accept there is not one that goes
directly to but there are traffic
controlled pedestrian crossings in the
locality I'm also very aware that I'm
also very aware that a large proportion
of the stretch of road surrounding this
site is hotels bed-and-breakfasts and
similar sort of sites in a sort of use
for buildings there are residential but
the majority are as I've said please I
do not want to hear anything from
members of the public I don't if I can
ask the members of the public to leave
all we have to have an adjournment I
don't want to have to do that I want you
to see this happening because that's
what's supposed to happen but you are
supposed to listen not comment at this
stage and I will insist upon that one
way or another
so there is a an abundance of hotels
bed-and-breakfast similar type of
businesses along the stretch on both
sides of the affairs possess pedestrians
that use those sites as far as I'm aware
code perfectly well with crossing that
road and indeed they use first they
cross through the furs I see people
walking through in fact I walk through
so I don't in my opinion do not think
that there is a major issue in terms of
pedestrian access and pedestrian use on
the anti-social behavior side if we were
to insist on having two point three
meter hedgerows surrounding the burning
pavilion I can understand why there
might be a concern if we were to insist
that they aren't there I think that
concern would be alleviated somewhat
it's also important to note that the
police station is right next door okay
can we just have a pause here because
I'm going to discuss with my legal
adviser what we can do I'm going to ask
the public to leave the room please we
are we should
okay we're gonna have an adjournment now
I'm gonna have a discussion with you
guys and then we'll come back to it so
we're going to adjourn for five minutes
okay and then we'll see what happens
next
Oh every day is a learning day right
okay so I shall go back to councillor
Richards the audience understands the
situation and I can hear from
counterfactually or somebody else are
matters of fact and I will if somebody
wants to after our discussion cancel
Richards thank you
you'll be pleased to know most of the
stuff that's going to create some
animosity is probably done my final
points are about the blocking up of the
pedestrian entrances and there's two
point three meter hedgerow
I think that's an awful idea and given
that we now have evidence from a third
party transport professional to suggest
that they are unnecessary I would be
seeking to have those removed not least
of which the drawings that we had of the
landscaping plan ah I mean that just
it's just awful and would very much
detract from the in itself which is
supposed to be made clear and visible so
with that contrary to councillor Charles
I would be proposing that we do grant
plan permission but we removed condition
for which is the blocking up of the
pedestrian ways and we removed and if it
doesn't actually say in the condition as
the need for a two point three meter
hedgerow I would suggest you remove the
need for that and load up all planting
okay obviously canister jars is a
proposal came first so councillor Barnes
well I feel very similar to the last
speaker it's a wonderful gift it's
probably not the right place I'm not
keen on the landscaping because as far
as I'm concerned that will cause
problems no doubt about it
I used that Road on me by Camby car it
is busy the speed of the traffic is very
low in my respect because it's usually
waiting at the
Lucian's or full look in the respective
crossing the road there's just a bit
between the two main roads between the
two crossings which I feel would be
reasonably safe so I abstain last time
because I wasn't sure about the trees I
have confirmation that the trees are
going to be saved or looked after so I'm
happy to go along with that the last
weekend okay counselor Perry Thank You
chair I got into becoming a counselor
about nearly five years ago and one of
the key risk reasons behind that was
that I wanted to listen to hear what
local residents had to say and I think
part of our role as counselors is to
hear what local communities have to say
I was certainly against this at the last
Planning Committee meeting because I was
I couldn't get my head around the
landscaping issue screening it and
blocking the pedestrian areas in
contrary to counsel Rich's view about
the pedestrians at the end of the day
this is a magnificent structure that's
going to attract an awful lot more
people to that particular area so it's
it's a bit of an unknown quantity as to
how many pedestrians and groups of
travelers on foot it's actually going to
attract the other thing is I feel I mean
obviously anything in that particular
area this is this is not a quick fix
this is not a temporary situation this
is for the heritage and the future of of
the town and my big concern is
but and we've heard it all before by
former councillors that they don't feel
it's in particularly the best site
that's not a clean planning reason to
refuse it we have to look at what's in
front of us and what I see in front of
me is that such a particular type of
building does need a bit of Vista it
does need for people to appreciate what
it has and therefore in itself in its
design and it is a beautiful gift I feel
it's out of character for this
particular site and therefore I'm siding
towards councillor Giles Giles is views
because of its nature character and also
I feel that because it up will be a
major tourist attraction because it is
so beautiful but it then will have an
impact on the neighbouring amenity so
there are two planning reasons that
would support me going against the
officers recommendation thank house just
noting Daniel reusing said councillor
fielding happy to just create a
temptation anything of this nature
anywhere would attract vandalism there
are perfectly good entrances into the
park further down I've used them which
could easily take
a zebra crossing or similar particularly
down rather Street that's wrong further
on down where there are those parking I
don't see any problems we've got to give
the permission based on the application
we see before us and I'm happy to go
along with it okay I'd like to say some
things as well on the second that by the
way yes yes I know we're looking for
search for a seconder for Molly's first
no I'm sorry we had a lot of letters
we've had a lot of people talking today
I think the issues are clear to all of
us that the residents have have
highlighted the many issues we are very
clear on that by now and I would I think
we need to send a message to the
applicant in this case that in hindsight
at least enough pre-application
consultation with residents wasn't done
it's it's absolutely up to the the
residents said to the applicant to do
that free application advice and they
may well not have thought it would be as
contentious as it was in hindsight
things are very easy easy to see but I
hope the applicant this council
recognizes that it could have done
better
in this case because it turns out that
it certainly could have done there's
lots of reasons to go over I think for
me the alternative locations argument
which isn't a planning reason you're
quite right
however mr. ding on behalf of Fujio
I think quite clearly said they were
very happy with the location they all
the dignitaries had their photos taken
there last year so I don't think we can
argue that it's not an appropriate place
from that point of view because
everybody seems to be happy with it I
completely go along with with the idea
that we can use the alternative highways
information that we've received from the
applicant to remove the high landscaping
scheme and condition perhaps a
lower-level landscaping scheme just for
artistic effect to be arranged with the
offices and also not to block up there's
there's accesses which also we do not
need to do and and and would be negative
for local residents one more thing I
think we need to add in is that there is
a memorial to Edith Cabell in this area
and that has to be sensitively we housed
closeby there's absolutely no reason it
can't be close by so I will be if it
gets to it I'm going to take legal
advice on this but I would like to have
a second to first for the for the
proposer to refuse right so I'm going to
seek a second and I've got one the
second if account of Giles proposal to
refuse is seconded by councillor Perry
on reasons of character oh I'm terribly
sorry
yes you may before we take a vote
I did tell councillor virtually that she
could answer points the fact that we
have discussed so we will hear from
counterfactually before we make a
decision okay
how long do you need under three minutes
okay thank you thank you
issue was raised that there are traffic
lights and pedestrian crossings to this
site that's not true
there are two pedestrian crossings which
actually go from mother's Street to the
island and a cross Grove Road to the
passage way down to shore tree field all
the accesses to this apex have to be
done on open traffic admittedly the one
little road that goes through across the
end of the impacts apex is slightly less
busy but actually that's quite often
where a lot of pedestrian accidents or
nearest and so actually happen so that
is it is there was no safe pedestrian
access to the to the apex the second was
the majority of being bees my
understanding is that there are ten
being bees and thirty five houses along
this area so that was factually
incorrect the issue about the police
station residents here have asked
regularly and been to the police station
to asked for help when the place is
actually being misused and there have
been some quite unpleasant incidents
there and and there was a tent actually
parked there last year as well and the
police actually refused to help there
because they say that it's a council
land so there have been some issues
there about gaining police help plus the
fact the police station is not open at
night when some of these issues are
particular point about pretty miserable
crossing further down the road to access
at the bottom that's not where tourists
walk they go down chestnut walk and I
have actually asked the county about the
possibility of extra posses there and
they've said that it will be do close
and they are not willing to look at it
at this moment in time
the points raised uh yeah well I mean I
have I have actually raised that before
there isn't only coach parking yes we
heard that okay thank you very much and
I must say thank you very much to the
audience tonight for but letting that
happen in a civilized manner
Thank You counselor I've been offered
the applicant a quick come back if they
want it yes they're just to three points
we'd like to raise I visited the site
today and I don't think we will need to
relocate the Edith Corelli memorial
which would be able to accommodate that
in its existing position I understand
that the police haven't raised any
objections to this application on the
anti-social behaviour grains and I just
like to come and a lot of the
allegations of the Highway Safety don't
be seen to be borne out by the accident
date from the highways data that we
commissioned from the county case
without soil actually thank you
okay that's we've gone above and beyond
where we normally go and we've that's
where we're going we're going 1:1 and
we're now going to take the vote are we
ready to take the vote okay so all those
in favor of refusing this application on
those grounds of out of character and
lack of tranquillity and the impact on
tranquility vote all those against
refusing okay so that has failed we have
another proposer
count sort of Richards to follow the
officer recommendation and grant did we
have a second death can sort of fielding
subject to not blocking up the entrances
removal of condition for removal of
condition and then the remove the
requirement for two point three meter
hedgerows so
low level planting great thank you no no
no we have it there anyway so okay so
with those additions or changes all
those in favor of granting the
application against okay so this we have
resolved to grant application 1802 641
I'm very sorry and thank you for your
cooperation
no urgent business meeting closed